I'm loving the finale right now like
there's so much people showing love it's
just like that like Joey's just licking
my neck right now it's real hot he
cooled me down I feel the love literally
and metaphorically and it's just it's
great like we have great people right
here like lorros is doing backstage
stuff she's amazing is a huge family Pro
everybody loves her face it's it's so
great to see the people that support us
and they're like part of the family too
you know because they're here they love
on us we love on them
the quality it's just like you know was
just solid across the board like I
watched other videos there final videos
and it was like so good I couldn't know
honestly good and I'm not saying that to
be politically correct I was just like
yeah this is really good I don't know
who's gonna take it I didn't know who
was gonna take because the top three was
so strong any bad weathers final video I
mean you saw the judges response to it
it was a unanimous like so such a good
thing but I mean the Clunes on an eagle
and Mathias is like I'm like you're a
freakin pop star like I don't even
understand these people Mathias is just
a very likable person like Tim said it
says I would I just like to check the
guy was just really nice humble it's
just like a nice guy
Malati yeah nice body kind of handsome
nice ears you know he's a cool guy
I think hope is something that I really
believe him it's something that I really
believe in NIU and I believe that there
isn't enough of it there isn't enough of
it in just young kids lives and like
just a little bit of hope a little bit
of inspiration you can just sounds
cheesy but just make this world so much
better once I realized what he was doing
how much he was doing by himself and not
only like like he was scoring his own
music and he was you know he so had
these like extensive shot lists and he
was like color correcting stuff it was
kind of I was like holy crap you're like
a Superman like filmmaker this is this
is incredible so that yeah that was
definitely that was very impressive to
me music videos do very well on YouTube
because they're so easily like enjoyed
you don't really have to get the humor
you don't really have to get it you're
just like I like the song right if I get
the video cool if not it looks pretty
yeah you know I mean I think they just
have that voice was there I mean and
it's like you know dudes gonna be like
that's cool girls will be like I love
you it's a lot of appeal there's a lot
yeah I think that's kind of what what
took it but I think all these guys I
mean everyone on the show definitely our
top three they're all gonna be
successful in their own right in the
Clunes need their own show weather
wherever that lives and send bad weather
I'm like I feel like I feel like I want
to watch a movie those guys yeah like
it's all like an SNL sort of weird thing
that I'm like I love it
my ultimate goal is to direct feature
films I started this YouTube thing with
that in mind but YouTube in getting in
with it and doing this whole experience
I just feel like it's it's really
cracking at that at that ultimate goal a
lot to say that it's it's changing this
the entire way we consume media and
create media so I'm gonna really ride
this out and see where like it's just
something that God bless me then I just
appreciate that to the max and but I
really thought Alex was gonna win I
thought I was gonna win I love him I
think he should I wanna I want your MF
to let him work at me him me and Megan
get advertised but I just wanna read it
screw my thighs yes ten thousand dollars
well so the three of us oh man that'd be
amazing so I want that that's what I
think the right way I want what the I do
that let's do that lines that's what I
wanted I mean we got a lot of stuff we
have a big announcement coming to August
first very big announcement stay tuned
stay tuned for that but yeah I mean
right now I mean we're just committed to
Ken you know trying to make content that
we love on our channel which is very
strange that's strange and weird but
never maybe ends in a fart joke too
often but really grown up
nope nope nope no no no but yeah I mean
I think that's really what we're
striving for and I mean if season three
if they'll have us back I mean we'll see
where it goes with you it would be a
blast to get in there and go wild again
so it is definitely a fun environment
yeah so somebody please go meet Andy
fickman
okay or maybe bad weather we'll just
tell us that next year honestly honestly
that's not a bad idea like they're so
funny like a you're like they would do
it well yeah I feel like we would have a
lot of fun doing it again but I feel
like if it's like a doctor who kind of
thing like stop you know and then it's
like oh this is the next you know
version it'd be great and they xks
now or I mean think about Mitch I mean
the nudity of that show alone would be
phenomenal the ratings would be through
the roof he just doesn't completely be
completely naked the entire time it's
not naked and afraid' or once they get
afraid they get afraid
yum yum EFT is has this video for geek
week that I play Google executive
teaching young young math how to be more
Asian and I'm white are you so what
that's where the irony comes from but ya
know it's really funny and then my good
friends Josh and Jacob who are there
beside me and they just kind of take it
way too far
it's a musical so it goes really far
near future I will actually have a
schedule for my videos I'm trying to do
that so I mean like trying to plan it
out I might do like advice like
relationship advice or just advice on
life blogs
i'ma trying to sketch it I'm not real
good at sketching if you notice I mean I
make dumb stuff like The Exorcist or
whatever exercisers a terrible terrible
video but yeah so I'm gonna try and keep
doing that hope you guys enjoy check it
out youtube.com slash yellow Baco you